congratulations on this honor so well
deserved you know I did a little
research your career spans more than 50
years you've got more than 100 acting
credits you've got five films currently
in post-production what is it that keeps
inspiring you and motivating you to to
reinvent yourself and do new things
well I I think first of all I've been
very lucky
um to have lasted this long and still be
having so much fun and
um uh I'm thrilled about being here I'm
so excited to meet all my fellow
honorees because I'm a big fan of every
single one of them and I'm so grateful
to be in a room with so many women
because I
you don't get to be in a room with so
many women usually
be there to support each other and
uplift each other that's it you've got
so many things going on that fans are so
excited about 13 years in the making
we're getting an avatar seat well how do
you feel about finally reaching this
moment and what do you hope the fans
take away from this it's a hell of a
movie it is an amazing story
a very emotional story a very personal
Story related Jim Cameron
and a great cast you know Zoe and Sam
and um and Stephen Lang and I get to
play a 14 year old girl
and um I just love everyone in it and
I'm so excited to let it go into the
world
um you know I think it's uh these films
are about our planet even though they're
far away from us and I think it's um
therefore more there's one really good
story but each each uh story is really
uh unto itself as well so and also it's
going to be like so dazzling to be in
the theater and experience it it's going
to be very different from the first one
right 13 years later I am so ready for
it what are three words to describe it
um
uh
wondrous
compelling
and exhilarating
I love that you've got Avatar now in the
works but you've done so many wonderful
films throughout your career I don't
know if you know but next year we'll
mark 35 years since Working Girl
I've never worked for somebody who was
younger than me before or for a woman
well there's a first time for everything
and there are reports that they're
rebooting it and Selena Gomez is
attached as a producer what do you know
about this do you want to be involved Oh
I thought she was going to play like the
Melanie Griffith part or something I
don't know anything what I read earlier
was that she was attached to produce and
I was like sigourney's got to be a part
of this somehow I don't know maybe I
could play the Aging old you know Mogul
or something
I don't have to imagine such a beloved
project it you know I'm glad they're
bringing it back it's a great story and
it's all about the women in this office
and
um you know it's it's a comedy but it's
about some real stuff so I think all the
stealing of dresses and everything is
very Timely
[Music]